so you start dating somebody new you
like him this is cool you're having fun
and say hey man I make a lot of money
what if I kind of want to buy her a nice
$3,000 purse to show her Who I am
hey let's go to a Louie Vuitton store I
love you girl I got you listen to calm
you know form when you're with me Micra
has the best type of stuff here's a
$3,500 Louie button oh my gosh you're so
amazing my ex never did this and guys or
your ex now of course you know well I
wish it was like my ex was it yes yeah
you walk around feeling so proud of
yourself what you don't realize is this
you've officially set an expectation of
if he buys me a Louis Vuitton bag two
months into it guess what next year I
want you to buy me a Louis Vuitton store
and if you don't it's a disappointment
because you can no longer go up what's
above a $3500 purse what is it yeah
you're gonna go by Chanel $5,500 purse
what's above that there's only one way
to go up if you go from a dirty $500
Louie Vuitton purse to $350 coach back
guess what she's gonna tell you you know
what babe used to love me babe what
happened I think we had a different
relationship used to buy me high quality
stuff coach it hurts my feelings you
screwed up because you spoiled them too
early rather than saying you know my
girl who's gonna be with me and it's
gonna be with me long to let me tell
what I'm gonna be doing after she shows
coming cuz he relationship is both ways
she shows me come we're together he
shows me commitment I'm gonna do this
I'm gonna do this but five years from
now ten years from now 15 years from now
and if he or she sticks around that may
be a keeper but if he or she doesn't
stick around because she wants more
Rivertown backs let her go des Jimmy
who's gonna buy that $3,500 back and six
months later she's gonna leave him for
another Jimmy that's gonna buy her the
next Chanel back meanwhile you save
yourself $22,000 on the bank account
number seven so listen I have this
friend she's very attractive very
attractive beautiful and she makes very
good money I've been working with her
for a while mentored she's done very
very good for self we can say she's
drop-dead gorgeous I'm not gonna name
who this she's very pretty we start
talking she's dating a guy
good-looking guy solid guy but I don't
know this guy but he's a good-looking
guy perfect she calls me for advice
about finances so anytime she calls I'm
talking to I'm always gonna assume that
hey maybe the boyfriend is also
listening all right okay no problem
I
is he is he not he's not we've known
each other for many many years great so
then I told us so so worried about what
relationships gone very serious you know
about great so have you had the
conversation with them about a prenup or
how you guys gonna manage finance it oh
my gosh why would I do that we love each
other I said I kind of know you love
each other but you got a kid and and
he's got kids and who's more important
your kid or him well of course my kid
well then that's great so you know I'm
saying like this kid is gonna rely on
you for the business that you run that
makes you millions of dollars per you
you got to make the right decision for
you because what if tomorrow something
changes how do I bring up that
conversation how do you have sex the
first time it's awkward the first time
right so a lot of people like to drink
before they have sex the first time
because I don't want to think a lot
right because its first time it's a
little bit uncomfortable for some people
you got to bring it up I don't know how
to bring it up you got to bring it up so
finally she brought it up and they had
the conversation and he was open to it
nothing happened with the relationship
they're still together guess what that
shows me maybe this guy's really
committed I'm not here for your money
good for you but she is now making the
right sound decision that's gonna
protect her wealth her net worth her
business and this guy is showing
commitment to say I'm not here for your
money I love you that is an ideal
situation why I recommend entrepreneurs
who are established that have already
made their millions of dollars to
protect their business and have this
conversation with them saying hey if we
get married this is something that's
important to me I want to have a serious
relationship if we get married we're
gonna have my money you're gonna have
your money and we're gonna have our
money and whatever we buy together is
our money but if you want to go out and
buy a you know $6,000 wheels for your
car that I don't want to buy you buy
with your money